hey guys don't forget Justine this is my
sister Jenna I'm gonna link in the
description to her channel what oh thank
you today is my birthday so today is my
birthday and to celebrate I'm going to
be number one making a cake and number
two the most important part about this
video is I set up a donation link for
charity water and I'm working with
charity water for so long you guys have
donated in the past too many wells that
we've built and I'm so excited because
today for my birthday we're gonna build
some wells and so this cake that I'm
gonna be doing yeah what are you you
haven't told me the plant and I'm glad
we're gonna make this into a cake and
then we're gonna put a cup in the middle
and put water in it okay yeah it makes
sense it makes sense in my mind yeah I
make sense so in addition to whatever
you guys donate I'm going to match the
donations up to five thousand dollars so
as soon as we hit five thousand dollars
that I'm donating five thousand dollars
well I mean I'd like to get twenty
thousand but that's a pretty high goal
yeah shoot for the stars all the infos
in the description and you guys can just
donate a dollar fifty cents whatever
anything will help and you guys can
leave me like little messages in the
little description and just know that we
are helping change people's lives which
is super exciting now we got to make the
cake to go with it funfetti the most
important part of baking would you like
to spray the pan that was too much no
it's okay did you get the sign through
this yes okay good you didn't put enough
stop God so I'm gonna let you do it I'm
doing it don't touch cuz usually I'm
like oh [ __ ] I'm like Oh cuz I didn't
charge up this
58 heart rate this is the best thing
I've ever got Wow I rip off the thing so
I know if they're expired and I just
throw it in there
Oh March 23rd there's still good Wow
do you want me to get you one too no I'm
okay but it's so cool look guys it
doesn't look nice nope you only have 120
bucks
it's removing our close-up shot Oh No
get me a water bottle 1/2 cup oil oh my
gosh look how close this is I almost
knocked this off
[Music]
because water is actually not really
even blue but water is portrayed as
being blue let's do this there's teal
and then BOOM
that is extremely concentrated yeah holy
moly
I've been mixing this for a very long
time my seafoam it looks actually quite
good we're going to be having it for my
birthday
we're gonna need I'm on it yep instead
of a bunch pan at 39 to 43 minutes Wow
that's my bedtime hey no wait oh God
Alexa set a timer for 39 minutes okay
we'll see you guys doing this Oh baby
our cake is it's out its out of the oven
let's take a look at it Hollis Buffy oh
wow just disregard that oh my goodness
I'm screwed oh no you believe I was
gonna do that Oh
oh boy oh wow oh shoot it's not done
it's done but like they're not done
nothing village not gone Oh make it work
to be fair no but I am yeah so we got
our cake that's not flat huh I'm just
gonna try to even this up just a little
Sheriff move the bundt pan yeah we don't
need that anymore
well lobby for you that's what I like
that's what I like oh man I made a
mistake
oh no see some maybe we should hurry up
and I said yeah maybe
okay pretty oh maybe because I'm not
very yeah I can do it it is over here
okay see you soon
[Music]
okay so now we're gonna put our water
cup in hey you're gonna decorate the
blue cake like some sprinkles mm-hmm
well that's asking a lot isn't it simple
it does look like a big donut all right
I think it's beautiful looks good look
at this I feel like you do put a bowl of
fish in there can we get a goldfish
tomorrow no-neck a little baby finish
then we have another pet and I'm gonna
be like Jenna I'm out of town I like
fish if my dog over well thank you guys
so much for watching you guys enjoyed
this video but most importantly please
please please check out the link that I
have in the description to my charity
water well and I'm hoping to reach a
goal of 20,000 so we'll see what we can
do we also made some cupcakes over on
Jenna's channel so go check out that
video as well if you want to see us
taste test this I'll be posting that on
my blog tomorrow so check that out I'll
see you later
hey did you see mommy